yeah that's how you know a gun range is
racist they don't even got a white
silhouette for you to shoot
you all right buddy this guy's giving me
feedback on every joke i don't know if
you guys are hearing this
that's pretty funny a minus anytime i
say some conservative [ __ ] he's like
there's a plus right there
it's [ __ ] ready to carry the
bald eagle out of this club
he's coming back in 2024 i feel it i
feel it
[Applause]
i saw this guy leave dead ass for 10
minutes as soon as i came on stage you
had to gather his emotions like two
[ __ ] indians jesus christ
oh my god he took his girl with him they
don't ever go men and women don't ever
go to the bathroom together that's not a
thing you
do you ever been like hey baby let's go
to the bathroom that's not some [ __ ] you
do
they left for 10 minutes they gave each
other a little pep talk like look we
paid
we got the drinks
i thought they had a nice white kid in
the middle he turned out to be muslim i
just don't know
i just don't know what's happening to
our country quite frankly
you know you got a bald eagle on the
front of the comedy club you would think
there'd be some good
clean american comedy
it's an easy target no i because
you say that because you probably own a
lot of guns i bet you know what an easy
target is
i mean i mean as you said when i got on
stage you're like i shot this
[ __ ] cardboard version
many times from 150 yards out i could
get him right between his eyes
ah you're gonna take it out on me
tomorrow the gut range i bet i like you
i really do you're just
you're just so drunk and you didn't know
i was here and it was all you know we
got a whole
awkward thing now you know you had no
idea what you're getting into and i you
know
fine that's fine this is a little bit
uncomfortable we'll get there but
that'll make you a bad guy you're a
great guy clearly you just you know
just every time you start to dislike my
skin just look at this eagle and be like
come back next week there's a guy named
colin coming i bet that's a good
that's a good clean american comic
oh my god you're a good dude i like you
but i know none of us expected to see
each other
i know it i know that in my heart this
is an open-minded wife
this not so much
this is a like a [ __ ] you know like
the rich dude who pretends he's liberal
you you hate this [ __ ] more than
me i bet
i bet
snowflake right this guy [ __ ]
snowflake
i gotta get the heat off me buddy i
can't i can't i gotta i gotta survive at
this point you know how this could turn
you know
i gotta give us a common enemy because
if i say the wrong thing that might be
it for me you know
i gotta give us a thing to hate together
and it's you what a [ __ ] right
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy what a cuck
[Laughter]
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]
you